ننتقل الان الى كيف ومؤتمر صحفي للرئيس
الاوكراني عنه باعلى درجات استخدمنا مئات
الالاف من الجنود ليس عشرات الالاف بل
مئات الالاف
كان هناك اعداد كبيره جدا من الجنود هل
كان من الممكن ان نصمت طوال هذا الوقت دون
تجهيز قوي للدفاع بالنسبه لي
رايت الكثير من الجرحى من تلك الجبهات في
اعداد كبيره وكنت انا
متواجدا هناك وكانوا الجنود خارقين عن
العاده وكل ما كان
كل ما كنا نحصل عليه وكنا نقدم حتى
الذخيره التي كانت باعداد قليله وكنا
نستخدم بركان كاسلحه وهذه وسائل دفاع قويه
واستخدمنا صواريخ اشترم
وصواريخ كاليبر
والصواريخ تاجر
انها اسلحه حديثه وهايمرز ايضا
كل هذه المعدات كانت
اجزاء من الحصن الذي بنيناه وهذه المعدات
كانت غائبه في البدايه ولكننا استخدمناها
في بخموت وفي الدمباط وهذا لم يكن متواجد
في بدايه
الاجتياح الروسي لاوكرانيا
ومن كان مسؤولا عن تجهيل
الدفاع في ذلك
القطاع خرده
يقودها تعلمين جيدا
[موسيقى]
في كل هذه الاتجاهات ابديسكا تعلمين ايضا
من موجود هناك هل تعلمين من كلا لا اعلم
اذا اعتقد انك لا تتحدثين الى الاشخاص
الصحيحين انا اتحدث لمختلف الاشخاص
والكثيرين
قالوا ان الدفاع كان غير كافيا في تلك
المناطق
اعتقد ان الرسائل التي حصلنا عليها من
باخموت ومن اولئك الاشخاص الذين لم يكونوا
متواجدين على خطوط النار ولكنهم قاموا
بتصوير الكثير من المقاطع الكثيرين من
هؤلاء الاشخاص اما
من كانوا يتواجدون على خطوط النار كانوا
يفهموا جيدا انهم استلموا كل الاسلحه
المتاحه اما بالنسبه
لتلك المناطق ترين كيف من الممكن ان تدافع
عن نفسك ضد قذائف المدافع ان البيوت
والمنازل قد دمرت تماما
عندما
يصاب المنزل
بصواريخ من عيار 125 و150 ما الذي يمكن ان
نعمل به
بمنزلا بمنزل يصاب
بالقذائف يجب ان نخرج المواطنين والسكان
والجنود من تلك
المناطق لا تستطيعين ان تدافعي
ان تدافع عن المنزل عندما يتهدم يجب ان
تنقذي الارواح تتحدثين عن امور متضاربه
تستطيعين ان تدافعي عن مدخل المدينه ولكن
ليس المنازل التي تقصف ان با المدينه
ولكننا تعرضنا لقوات ضخمه جدا وكنا
نفهم جيدا عن نبات اصبح مغناطيسا للعدو
ومن يقول لكم انه كان من الممكن ان
تدافعي عن منزل من خمس طوابق ضد القذائف
الصواريخيه اعتقد ان هذا ليس عادلا
دعونا نستمع
لصحفي اخر سيدي انا الكسنكا
ما هي
المشاعر
التي
تشعر بها في المحكمه العليا
[موسيقى]
بعد يقول انه
النظام
القضائي مزدحم
واصبحت هناك الكثير من القضايا هل هذا شيء
جيد ام لا اعتقد ان رئيس المحكمه ان رئيس
المحكمه العليا قد القي القبض عليه
وسجن ببعض التهم فهل هذا يمثل
ويثبت ان هذه جهه ممكن ان نثق بها ام لا
اذا كان حتى الرئيس قد سجن في حاله قيامه
ببعض الجرائم فهذا يعني ان هذه جهه تستحق
الثقه
اذا كانت قد بدات في العمل
ارواح جديده دون اخفاء اي اسرار
اعتقد
ان ان هذا قد يكون غيرك كافيا
ولكن
الكثيرين من القضاه لم يمروا
بانتخابات
بمجالس
ترشيحيه وكان من ان يجب ان نقوم ببرنامج
جاد جدا في هذا النطاق
وكان يجب ان نقوم بخطوات قاسيه جدا لتطهير
نظام القضاء وسوف نرى ما الذي قمنا به من
تغييرات في المجال القضائي والقانون وهذا
ما نقوم بتحضير له
[موسيقى]
الخارقين في الشرق وهناك مجموعه اخرى من
الشعب الخارق الذي لا يزال يعيش هناك او
يعود لتلك المناطق
والمناطق حيث العمليات العسكريه والمناطق
المحرره في قضاء في ضواحي خارقف ولوجانك
هناك في تغير مستمر
نرى كيف يسعد المواطنين باستقبال القوات
الاوكرانيه المسلحه
[موسيقى]
ولكن في الشتاء كانت الاوضاع
صعبه جدا بسبب انتظارهم لهجمات روسيه
عكسيه
ولكني اعتقد ان الشعب منزعج لان تلك
المناطق قد قطعت المياه فيها والكهرباء
وهناك الكثير من
المنازل المدمره ولكن
الشعب والسكان يعيشون في شقق من غرفه
واحده
ويطلبون من المتطوعين صيانه سقف المنزل
سؤالي هل هناك خطه استراتيجيه
لمساعده السكان الان ليس غدا وليس بعد
نهايه الحرب لانهم يعودون لمنازلهم
ويريدون ان يعيشوا على ارض وطنهم اما سؤال
اسمحي لي ان اجيب على هذا السؤال مع كل
احترام حتى لا انسى تفاصيل بالنسبه لسؤال
الاول الشعب الذين عادوا للمناطق حيث
تبادل اطلاق النار لديهم الحق ان يعيشوا
تحت سقف على حساب الحكم وهل هذا واقع نعم
هذا واقع القضيه الثانيه كونهم يعودوا الى
منازلهم للاسف سوف اقدم لك مثل
مثل
الاسر الذين يعيشون من 11 شخص ولا يريدون
ان
يلجاوا لمناطق اخرى
وينتظرون لا يريدون الخروج من المنطقه
ماذا ينتظرون هل ينتظرون الهجمات الروسيه
انا استطيع ان اقدم لك امثله متعدده
اذا كانت حكومتنا للاسف
لا تستطيع ان تساعد من تعرضوا للضرر
ونحاول ان ننقلهم لمناطق اخرى ونقدم لهم
نكتفي بهذا القدر من المؤتمر الصحفي الذي
يعقده الرئيس الاوكراني فلودر